I imagine that you all have images of
Robert Frost and actual images in your
mind. Uh, when you, uh, when you,
when you think of this, this poet,
he's a familiar face in
American literature, uh,
and I gathered some of them that
seemed representative, uh, here,
here is,
this is frost and old age as an
American barred from a magazine.
Uh,
this is,
this is the frost that you probably
know as if he were born with white hair,
right? Uh, and, uh, uh, kind of, uh, well,
kindly, uh, and, uh, monumental, uh,
and yet approachable a
figure, uh, that, uh,
is familiar from American
school rooms. Uh, here's a,
another image of that Same Guy,
Robert Frost,
painted by Grandma Cox,
uh, uh, reminding us of,
of frost as a kind of linked
to 19th century life, uh,
to, uh, to rural Vermont. Uh, another,
uh,
another image of froth.
This one from the time it's
just a little story. Uh,
President Hails Bond with Frost. That
president would be John F. Kennedy,
uh,
on TV.
He extols poet who calls new frontier,
age of poetry and power.
Uh,
and perhaps you have seen images of,
of frost reading his poem,
the gift outright at
Kennedy's inauguration. Uh,
it was a kind of powerful moment
in American culture where, uh,
the president allied himself
with poetry, uh, in this way,
uh, oh, more pictures. This is,
you know, Frost with grandchildren,
frost with his pet calves.
He was kind to animals.
Uh, uh, and if farmer,
uh, this one I like, this
is frost with a stick, uh,
uh, for us or the branch. You can think
about that. Uh, when you read Birches,
uh, this is, uh, uh, you know,
a frost boyish even in
age, uh, for us, uh,
who also likes to play and even
who looks just a little bit,
don't you think malevolent?
Uh,
all of these images would
seem to make for us,
not a modern poet at all,
not a modern poet in the sense that
Elliot and pound established that is
difficult poet in ways that
I suggested last Wednesday,
a poet resistant to ordinary language
and common frames of Reference, uh,
formerly innovative,
disorienting or Bain metropolitan,
I think of 19th century art as,
as being horizontal.
Uh, and, and, you know,
stretched out, uh, uh, like a,
a agricultural life in New England.
Uh,
and modernism is all about verticality.
from a certain angle.
This is the Stieglitz, uh,
picture city of ambition.
I showed you last, uh,
last Wednesday, uh, another
pairing, uh, this, this, uh,
wonderful,
uh,
landscape by Martin Johnson heed
and we could contrast it with,
uh, these images of Brooklyn
Bridge by Walker Evans,
where even underneath the bridge, the
bridge seems to, you know, a, a, a,
a figure of crossing, uh,
themes here to rise up, uh,
and out of, um, uh, the,
uh, the city and the river.
Uh, this is, this is frost.
Before he had white hair,
a frost at, at 18, uh,
which is I, I believe, uh,
uh,
1892 or so,
boyish. And his, his first book, uh, is,
is entitled a boys will, uh, uh,
Boys Will Robert Frost.
This is a cover of the first edition that
you can go over to a key and see when
you, when you open it up and
look at the table of contents,
you see, uh, titles of poems. Uh,
and underneath those titles are
little legends. Uh, and Moralization,
uh, into my own title, uh, Legend.
The youth is persuaded that he will
be rather more than less himself.
We're having forsworn
the world, uh, or, uh,
storm fear. He is afraid
of his own isolation. Uh,
uh, these, uh, these are our, our poems.
In other words that, uh, uh, you know,
come with, with little labels to tell
you what they mean and what they're about
bout,
uh,
modernism in Elliot and pound is in,
in some ways is,
is founded on expatriation on,
on, on a kind of internationalism.
Frost's poetry seems
resolutely American or,
uh,
at any rate it seems to be there
is in fact a another frost,
a modern and modernist frost,
a a frost that is in fact as
international, uh, as pound.
And Elliot, uh, who began his career,
in fact,
uh,
beside them as a London ex patriot.
This is, uh, this, this is
more of a table of contents.
You can see how it's
laid out. Uh, this is,
this is the frost who published
that book. Uh, this is frost at 39,
uh, frost. In a suit
made by a London Taylor,
uh, in London. Uh, and when we
go to the title page of a boys,
will we see that, uh, this, uh,
New England poet publishes his
first book, in fact, in London, uh,
in 1913, uh, they're a new Oxford Street,
interesting north of Boston.
Uh,
a a great a book that follows a boys will,
uh, uh, is, uh, it's, you know, is a,
is a title that locates these
poems in a specific place in, uh,
northern New England. Uh, it to, uh,
is published in London, uh, this time, uh,
on Bloomsbury street. You don't really
think of frost as part of Bloomsbury,
do you? Uh, but there he is publishing
his book, uh, in that place.
Just like Prufrock,
uh,
also published I'm Bloomsbury
Street, uh, this in 1917,
uh, north of Boston in 1915, uh,
you remember that table of contents
page I showed you a moment ago with the
titles and the moralization
that a frost has,
her boys will well, Uhm,
here's the, here's the, the
modernist table of contents of,
of Prufrock.
And of course you and we know,
well,
what would the legend for the
love song of j l for Prufrock be?
He wanders around in a melancholy
way quoting hamlet for, well,
no, it, it, it, it, uh,
uh, Elliot didn't do that.
Uh, when we look at the table
of contents of this book,
which is north of Boston, well, it
looks a lot like Elliot's, uh, those,
those little tags that seem
to explain the poetry, uh,
have disappeared.
And instead we simply have the titles
of these very great poems mending wall,
the death of the hired man,
the mountain, uh, home burial.
Uh, there's something, uh, in, in, uh,
Elliot's the presentation of Elliot's
work and indeed in the work itself that is
a fronting resistant, uh, impersonal, uh,
and the topography, the presentation
of the book, uh, is part of that.
Um, it, it's, it's part of, uh,
Elliot's whole aesthetic, uh,
but, uh, north of Boston.
Well, you know, uh,
when we start looking at
these two books together,
it seems to share some of the
properties of Elliot's book. Uh,
and indeed the poems that we find when we,
um,
opened that book, uh, also have,
have things in common with
Elliot's. The other frost, uh,
not the simple, uh,
familiar monumental frost.
But the frost who is a modernist poet
who begins writing in London, uh,
is really quite as cosmopolitan,
quite as learned,
uh, as, as pounds and
Elliot at this moment. Uh,
and yet he uses his
learning, uh, differently.
He uses it very often by concealing it.
In fact,
well,
let me turn from
pictures to text
on your handout today. The
handout number two. Uh,
we have, uh, well there's several
quotations from a frosts letters.
And, uh, let's look at the,
the first one first, uh,
for us says, uh, at the time that
he's publishing a boys will, uh,
to a friend. Uh, you mustn't
take me too seriously.
If I now proceed to brag a bit
about my exploits as a poet.
There was one qualifying
fact always to bear in mind.
There is a kind of success
called of esteem and butters.
No parsnips.
Uh,
it means a success with the critical
few who are supposed to know,
but really to arrive where I can stand
on my legs as a poet and nothing else.
I must get outside that circle to the
general reader who buys books and they're
thousands. I may not be able to
do that. I believe in doing it.
Don't you doubt me there? I want to
be a poet for all sorts and kinds.
I could never make a merit of being caviar
to the crowd the way my quasi friend
pound does.
I want to reach out and would,
if I were a thing,
I could do it.
If it were a thing I could
do by taking thought.
Well,
frost wishes to be so subtle as
to seem all together obvious.
It's not just that he seems obvious,
but it's really subtle. Rather,
his subtlety shows itself in his
deliberate concealment of it,
in the ways in which he masks himself
and obviousness the problems that that
Frost's poetry poses for us as,
as readers are not problems of reference.
Uh, they can't be solved by footnotes.
Compare the footnotes in the
frost poems to the footnotes, uh,
in, in the Norton that you
find next to, uh, Elliot or,
or Palms and the problems that frost
poses are problems of interpretation,
uh,
problems that provoke you to ask
not what does he mean exactly,
uh, but how does he mean that, uh,
is he joking or is he serious?
Is there something on his mind that
he's not saying the wonder of frost is,
is really in his tone,
his way of saying things without
saying them in so many words.
Now, uh, this guy, all of his, uh,
because that's what it entails.
This guile is something temperamental.
I think it came naturally to him,
but it also reflects a
specific literary situation.
The popular old fashioned frost
in the elite modern frost.
These roles point to a division in the
audiences for poetry that emerges clearly
in this period. Uh, the,
the frost to,
uh,
writes a familiar crafted lyric that
would have been easily recognizable as
poetry. Uh, and, and that we could
give a little tag to after its title.
Uh, well, contrast this with, um, uh,
the poet of the wasteland,
uh, say, uh, whose work, uh,
would not have been
recognizable to, uh, uh,
many readers as poetry,
uh,
and indeed was not a PA.
On one level,
frost was spoke for and to,
uh,
in audience trained by the genteel poetry
of late 19th century America readers
who loved Longfellow,
uh, the fireside poets,
poets who published in Victorian
popular magazines and wrote those guilt
embossed books that,
uh,
cultured families kept behind
glass bookcases and that
you can still find at tag
sales on a New England Greens.
That's the obvious frost,
the one that the subtle frost
in many ways constructed, uh,
aiming all the time,
not at a general reader at all,
but at an elite reader of the new tiny
circulation little magazines where,
uh,
the work of Elliot Williams',
Steven's Moore and others
were first published.
Those magazines I showed you last week.
Magazines like Broome or blast or
a rogue or the criterion a frost.
There's duplicity in Frost's
poetry. Uh, and there's, uh,
there's a certain doubleness
in the, uh, um, uh,
figured that he projects,
uh, as a poet, uh,
I like to think of his
obsession with double meanings,
which he has as,
as a,
as a way of responding to a division
in culture between popular in elite
readers, uh, uh, division
that he saw as expressive of,
um, uh, uh,
division in American culture between well,
money in esteem business and art.
Uh,
in that quotation I,
I read for you a few moments ago,
a frost opposes two kinds of success,
one of esteem,
uh, that success with the critical
few that butter's no parsnips.
You can see he brings in the
kind of folksy term to, uh,
well to what, to um, a
disdain that kind of, uh,
success or put it in its place.
And on the other hand,
a success with the general reader
who buys books in their thousands,
uh, frost, one at both.
The opposition is between poetry that
makes money and poetry that precisely
because it is good poetry is
modern poetry defines it does not,
uh,
notice that the latter kind of poetry,
the good kind that butter's note.
No parsnips a is
associated here with frost,
quasi friend pound instead of
butter pound rights caviar.
Uh, but you know, it kind of a
European thing, right? Uh, caviar,
uh,
by contrast a frost as declaring his
ambition to reach out to a large audience.
Uh,
it is for frost,
a frankly economic ambition by becoming
a poet for all sorts in kines frost,
intense as he says to arrive where I can
stand on my legs as a poet and nothing
else. Uh, this is this
ambition for a career,
but it's also a desire for
personal autonomy for frost.
Poetry is invested with a,
with a longing for autonomy and in
well both simple and complex sense.
Census.
He wants to use poetry to
stand on his own two legs.
He sees it specifically.
And this is important as a form of
work that will allow him to be self
sufficient.
And self-determining frost was
born in 1874 into a working family.
Uh,
his father's death when frost was a
boy represented among other things in
economic crisis for his family.
Cross gluing was erratic.
This is impressive.
He dropped out of both Dartmouth
and Harvard, uh, and he did so,
uh, to take laboring jobs, uh,
each time enacting a conflict between
intellectual life and manual labor that
would be a persistent and
central theme of his poetry.
He worked at all sorts of
jobs, uh, in factories,
a mill on a newspaper. He
was a school teacher. Uh,
and of course he was a farmer too.
Uh,
when his grandfather
gave him a farm to work,
which he did for 10 years
in Derry, New Hampshire. Uh,
it's in fact at the end of this period
that frost moved himself and his family
to England,
uh,
in a last ditch bid to make literary
contacts and advance his career as a poet.
It was first in England that frost
publish the books that established his
reputation as the pasture
poet of New England,
a poet whose authority seemed to rest
on his being rooted in his region
once he returned to New England in 1916
after north of Boston success followed
on success.
Poetry was a way for
frost out of manual labor,
but it was also a form of work for
frost that was opposed to manual labor.
It was an escape from it, a way
of transcending it, but also, uh,
in many ways allied to it valuable
because it could be a form of productive
labor. Something he could
use to butter is parsnips.
Uh, these concerns that I'm
laying out all inform his poetry.
Uh,
they,
they structure frosts work as a poet
and his ongoing inquiry into that work.
Frost poems perform a kind
of phenomenology of work,
of labor.
They say what it is like to
work at something in so doing,
uh,
they are always also brooding on what
it is like to read and write poems.
Uh,
this is the case with mowing a,
which is in your packet
from Ras. Uh, and, uh, uh,
is an example of one of these
frosty and poems about work.
Let me read it for you.
There was never a sound beside the
wood but one and that was my long side
whispering to the ground.
What was it?
It whispered.
I knew not well myself.
Perhaps it was something
about the heat of the sun,
something perhaps about the lack of sound.
And that was why I
whispered and did not speak.
It was no dream of the gift of idle
hours or easy gold at the hand of Fay or
Elf.
Anything more than the truth would have
seemed to week to the earnest love that
laid the swale in rows,
not without feeble pointed
spikes of flowers, Pale,
orchesis and scared a bright green snake.
The fact is the sweetest
dream that Labor knows
my long side whispered
and left the hey to make.
This is a, uh, a monologue
by, uh, a worker, a mower,
a,
it is a sonnet to,
to sort of song of song of a worker.
Uh,
notice that
frost is interested at once
in the presence of a sound,
the sound of a solitary worker,
uh,
or to be more precise the sound
of the tool of the worker.
The sound is the sign of his work.
And it raises a specifically
a interpretive question.
What is the message of the work
that the man does? What does it,
what is it saying and what is its meaning?
What was it?
It whispered.
The side is one of many tools in frost.
I asked you to pay it
tension to two tools in his,
his poetry as you read it over the
weekend to work in frost is to use a tool,
tools mediate the worker's
relation to the world.
Uh,
it's what the worker uses to
do things and to make things.
Things are not made up in frost,
uh,
not made up in the sense of imagined
called up out of thin air like fairies and
elves. Instead, things in frost are,
are made in the sense of constructed.
There are the products of specific
acts, the acts of, of a worker.
I think of of other tools in
those poems. Uh, there's the,
the spade in home burial,
uh,
the spade that's used to bury
the couple's little child.
I'll talk more about that palm next time.
There's the,
uh, the ladder to heaven in after
apple picking a, it's a ladder,
you know, uh, use to, um, uh,
send the tree kind of tool of a scent
that's kind of tool for getting fruit.
Uh, and then there's the
terrible chainsaw and out out,
uh,
in mowing the size makes
a sound as it cuts.
Uh, and that sound is delicate.
It's a, it's quiet, it whispers,
but cutting is something
fearful and forceful.
It's a kind of controlled violence.
Uh,
frost takes it for granted that we will
remember that the side as a conventional
image for time,
which harvests all of us to death,
time and death. Uh, these
are the forces that the, uh,
worker works against, uh, and
tries to Marshall, uh, in,
in,
uh,
the process of working his will in
the world to make his way in it,
to earn his living,
to stand on his own two feet.
But these, these forces are not
something that, uh, the man,
uh, controls, uh, as a, as a
simple extension of himself,
tools in frost are tricky.
You have to learn how to use them.
They have in frost to kind of, uh,
independent objective existence.
Uh,
remember out, out this is, if you look
on page two 13, and your, your Norton,
uh, well I'll, I'll read from
the middle of the, the poem.
A boy is out, uh, sawing. Uh,
his sister stood beside them.
The group, he's not alone.
He's with others in her apron
to tell them supper at the word,
the saw as if to prove saws,
knew what supper meant,
leaped out at the boy's
hand or seem to leap.
He must have given the hand.
However it was neither refuse the meeting,
but the hand,
the boys first outcry was a rueful laugh
as he swung toward them holding up the
hand. Half an appeal, but half as
if to keep the life from spilling.
Then the boy saw all,
since he was old enough to know big boy
doing a man's work though a child at
heart,
he saw all spoiled.
Don't let them cut my hand off the doctor
when he comes. Don't let them sister.
So,
but the hand was already
gone and the boy dies.
Uh, it's, it's, uh, an
extraordinarily powerful poem,
uh, this saw rather than whispering
it's snarls and rattles, uh,
ultimately it takes the life,
the worker,
it reminds the worker that, uh, uh,
it has the power of death,
the force that the worker only
access accesses through the tool.
Although a frost tools give the worker
a way to impose his will on the world.
The tool is part of the object world and
it declares here brutally and cruelly
that the workers will,
is limited and subject
to the tools he uses
in mowing.
The palms lines
are like sweeps of the size
as it lays down rows of swale.
Fros wants us to think about that.
He wants us to see the, the road.
The harvest had rose as being like
lines of verse. It's an ancient,
uh, association, uh,
from classical poetry.
The word Swale is interesting.
You hear in it,
the s and the w, uh, the
two key sounds of this poem,
uh,
which are the sounds of the whispering
Saif frost loves verbal sounds,
uh, and he loves to play with
their metaphorical associations.
He invites us to hear the sweep of
the size in those s sounds themselves,
I think. And maybe even to
hear the workers huff and puff,
uh,
his rhythmic exhalation in the Wus which
alternate and interact with those ss,
the whisper of the side.
Then this is what the poem is all about.
The whisper is not.
Frost specifies a dream
of the gift of idle hours.
Poetry is not,
that is to say a leisure
class activity for us.
This is writing against the romantic
idea that poetry is written in, repose
received passively as inspiration.
Poetry in frost is action,
uh, not a matter as,
as Wordsworth would say,
of emotion recollected in tranquility.
Frost is also here specifically writing
against the early poetry of Yates,
which you'll read next week.
Uh,
poetry that that finds reality exactly
in dream and then has plenty of fairies
and elves in it.
A fraud.
A frost is not after easy gold,
but rather hard earned wages.
A dream. Uh, here.
Frost implies that it is something.
Dream is something more than
the truth. He has that, that
anything more than the truth would have
seem too weak to the earnest love that
laid the swale and rose. Uh,
that's an interesting phrase.
More than the truth.
Why not less?
Why isn't dream less than the truth?
Uh,
frost has made a
suggestive choice of words.
Truth is something less
than dream in frost.
Truth is life sized.
Uh, to get down to it,
you have to cut away what is not true.
What is inflated beside the
point, uh, excess ornament.
The truth is something that you get
down to. Uh, the truth is a reduction,
a simplification.
It is what is fit for the earnest
love that is working for truth.
Love.
This is a crucial word in frost.
You don't think of frost
as a, as a love poet. Uh,
there are lot of ponds in
frost, uh, uh, and yet,
um, uh, even apart from those,
there are many poems that use that word
love often in a crucial places in the
poems. Uh, in fact,
love and desire are really at
the center of Frost's poetry.
Uh,
so far I've been stressing a kind
of anti romantic side of frost,
uh, uh, how he seems to be saying
nothing but the facts please.
But the fact he says in that next to
last line is the sweetest dream of labor
and it is earnest love that is doing this.
Cutting labor loves labor dreams.
When we look carefully at this poem,
in fact,
the distinction that frost seems to make
between fact and dream starts to give
way.
Let me go back to the sound of this work.
What was it?
It whispered
note fros use of words
like something and perhaps,
uh, these are words you are not
supposed to use. And in poems or, or,
or even writing about poems, uh, in frost,
there is here this, uh, uh, explicit,
deliberate, calculated vagueness,
a withholding of certainty that allows
a range of possible meanings to be
entertained, held open. It's a,
it's a rhetorical and conceptual
move that I think is analogous to the
whispering of the size.
What I mean is, is that, uh,
this tool doesn't speak
loudly, it whispers, uh,
and you have to lean forward to hear it.
The same is true with the
poem with any frost poem,
uh,
except
that line 13 seems to violate that
it seems to violate that principle.
The fact is the sweetest dream
that Labor knows well here.
Frostings to be spelling things out,
making a declaration, making a statement,
saying what the fact is, uh, in
theming to celebrate the literal, uh,
the fact is the sweetest
stream that Labor knows.
Importantly though, that's not
the last thing. The poem says,
what difference would it make? Had
Frost as he could have, I suppose,
have reversed the order
of lines 13 and 14.
Line 13 stands out as if
almost as if out of the poem,
uh, as if out of time, as a,
as a kind of fact or truth,
a fixed principle, a that is stated
in the kind of eternal present.
The fact is like no other
sentence in this poem
had frost decided to end the poem there.
Uh,
he would have said or seem to be saying,
this is what it's all about.
It would, it would be like one of
those morals, uh, following the, the,
the titles of his pump. But
in fact, he doesn't end there.
Uh,
he doesn't make so clear a declaration.
Line 14 returns us to the
work of mowing my long side,
the whispered and left the hay to make
returns us to the work of mowing and the
work of reading,
uh,
an interpretation in deciphering the poem
ends with an image of process and not
have product,
uh,
an image of the process of labor.
The implication is that it is the
same way for the poet who lays the s,
uh, his words in, in rows, uh, in those,
those, that rose of swale that
are his lines of verse the Hay.
That is well, what the payoff, uh,
what the poem is all about,
what mowing is all about. Uh,
the hay isn't handed over to you.
Uh,
it's rather left to make a,
that's a rich phrase.
What frost gives you here in elsewhere
is a poetry that leaves its meanings to
make all the time.
Frost poetry is engaged in,
uh,
construing constructing,
constituting facts,
which means it doesn't give us
the truth as if it were a product,
a fashioned object. Rather.
It gives us a, a process,
an act of fashioning,
an act that is involved with
dreams and desire and with love.
Facts are, are made and not found
in, in Frost's poetry of work.
And this is to say that the process
by which facts are made is, uh,
well, it's like work in is therefore, um,
well it's something daily, ordinary,
ongoing.
And for these reasons in completable,
uh,
it's something that we have to do over
and over again that is making up the
world.
Poetry is a response to the daily
necessity of getting the world right.
Steven said that,
but frost could have said it
to a meeting in frost poems,
uh,
as in the world that they evoke a,
it has to be interpreted every day.
It has to be in that sense
worked for again and again.
Well,
let me use this poem as a,
as a way into now talking
about sound and more actual,
more, more literal ways,
uh, in Frost's poetry. Uh,
and to begin with you to think
a little bit about meter, uh,
in fact and what frost does with it.
Uh,
let me go back to the handout
where we've got more passages from,
for us letters. Uh, and,
uh,
in particular
what for us has to say about
something he calls the sound of sense,
although he says in that first quotation
that, well, he doesn't like to brag.
I alone have English
writers have consciously set
myself to make music out of
what I may call the sound of.
Since this is an ambitious guy,
uh,
now it is possible to have sense without
the sound of sense as much prose that
is supposed to pass muster but makes
very dull reading and the sound of sensor
that sense as an Alice in wonderland,
which makes anything but dull reading.
This is a wonderful metaphor,
the best place to get the abstract sound
of census from voices behind a door
that cuts off the words you understand
what frost meantime that he's,
he wants us to think about how we
could understand what people are saying
without,
uh,
taking in the words that they're using
simply a by catching the tones and
rhythms of their exchanges.
The sound of sense.
Then you get that it is the
abstract vitality of our speech.
It is pure sound,
pure form one who concerns himself with
it more than the subject is an artist.
But remember,
we're still talking merely of the raw
material of poetry and ear and an appetite
for these sounds of sense is the
first qualification of a writer,
be it of prose or verse.
But if one is to be a poet,
he must learn to get cadences
by skillfully breaking
the sounds of sense with
all their irregularity of accent.
Okay.
Across the regular beat of the meter
verse in which there is nothing but
the beat of the meter furnished by the
accents of the polysyllabic words we
call dog role versus not that neither is
the,
is it the sound of sense alone?
It is the resultant from those two.
There are only two or three meters
that are worth anything. Uh,
we depend for a variety on the infinite
play of accents in the sound of sense.
Fros sound, sound of sense. Uh,
the abstract vitality of our speech.
It has to do exactly with
how people say what they say.
These are our,
uh,
dimensions of communication that I've
been identifying in mowing with the
whisper of the side. That is a tone
of meaning or a way of meaning.
Uh, the sound of sense,
it represents a common,
common vernacular.
Elements of speech.
The sounds of sense are all
part of language in use, uh,
which people are using to do things with.
But for us, justice, uh, poetry is
not only that, it's something more,
it's the sound of senses.
He says broken.
And that's another interesting metaphor.
It's broken.
He says skillfully across
the beat of the meter.
A meter is something regular.
It's a fixed scheme.
It's inflexible as frost conceives of it.
Here,
the speaking voice by contrast
is something idiosyncratic.
Your regular particular,
uh,
ms second quotation or rather the last
on the page with the second one about the
subject. Um, for us says,
my versification seems to bother people
more than I should have expected because
he seemed to ears tutored in 19th
century norms to have a kind of,
uh, a rough and irregular, uh, um,
metric,
I suppose because I've been so long
accustomed to thinking of it in my own
private way.
It is as simple as this.
There are the very regular preestablished
accent and measure of blank first
blank first. That is, and I'll
explain it, uh, unrivaled.
I ambig pentameter and there are the
very irregular accent in measure of
speaking intonation.
I am never more pleased than when I can
get these into strained relations for us
wants to create a sound effect of
strained relation in his poetry,
uh, where a strained relation
between speech and meet her.
I like to, and again, the same word.
I like to drag and break the intonation
across the meter as waves first comb and
then break stumbling on the shingle.
And now I'm writing a poem. It seems,
uh,
that's all he says,
but it's no mere figure of speech though
one can make figures enough about it.
Uh, and in fact, uh, you can see for
us doing that in his poetry very often,
uh,
strained relation,
this tension between speech and pattern,
uh,
suggest the tension between all
sorts of contending forces in frost,
the vernacular and the literary,
the concrete and the abstract flux fixity
the individual will and material fact,
the special sound of Frost poems,
uh,
results from the tensions between these
pairs of opposing forces as they are
embodied in his language.
To approach this,
uh,
you'll need to know a
little bit about meter.
Uh, in fact, uh, a rough grasp
on traditional English meter is,
is essential to frost.
And it's also important to other
poets. We'll read to Stevens, say,
uh, or to crane or to Auden or bishop. Uh,
obviously these are, these are our,
our poets, uh, uh, who, who work, uh,
usually in, in, uh,
quite traditional meters.
And yet it's also important,
uh,
for reading pound and for reading
Eliot and for reading more, uh,
who sound the way they do,
uh,
partly because they make a
point of not writing Pentameter,
the meter that frost often,
but not always chooses.
Uh, how many, uh, of, you know what I am?
The pentameter is don't be
shy. Let's see, I sat with,
uh, okay. Um,
I'm going to spend a little bit of time
at the beginning of class next time, uh,
talking about it and, and, uh, working
with you a little bit. Uh, as we, uh, uh,
read, um, uh, frost in particular, we can,
we can use the palm birches,
uh, to, to do that. Uh,
don't be distressed if you're
unfamiliar with it. Uh, um, knowing,
uh, what, uh, I ambit
pentameter is, is not a, uh,
a gift of birth, but rather, uh,
something that comes through
a little bit of practice,
which means you have to work at
it a little bit. Uh, and I will,
in order to enable you to do
that, uh, give you, uh, a well,
or I actually asked that the
tfs in section two, a handout,
a meter exercise that you
can do for next week, um,
when, uh, when you leave today, uh,
I would like to, uh, collect, uh,
cards just to figure out how many
of us there are. Um, and, uh,
as I say on Wednesday, uh,
between the online, um,
registration, uh, and, um, uh, are, um,
uh, work on it in a class, we should
be able to get our sections ordered.
So see you on Wednesday.